good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Wednesday hum
day where CEO bring amount bring him out
hey clone hid and how good Theo is it
was actually very sad Theo spending some
time at his grandparents this weekend
and we dropped him off last night and I
was in the bathtub like taking the
longest bath ever because something was
wrong with us yesterday like I rewatched
our show and the whole day like I was
completely out of commission and so I
took like a like a two hour bath like in
an attempt to feel something and then
dropped him off at his parents while I
was in the tub so like he was just like
literally taken from me without even
like saying goodbye and last night it's
very very rare that I sleep in my own
bed without Theo like if I want or if
I'm a vacation like I can I can
rationalize that why I'm not a fee abut
like being in my own home
and like not having feel like in my bed
it felt it felt horrible that ain't
right man yeah yesterday
okay so there's definitely a direct
correlation between the fact that we got
these shots and some experts for
commenting that yes if if we got shots
there's a direct correlation between us
getting shots and having our first and
only ever 28 minute episode like we were
there is science there is science behind
it right and the first and only ever
episode where I wore a robe on the show
like oj hurts like we were just in a fog
like I feel like I was just on autopilot
I think it was just a side effect of the
shot was extreme exhaustion and yeah
yesterday was just a weird one but I'm
glad that there was an explanation as to
why we were both feeling that way like
very common I'm feeling better today
though you know I'm always my standard
level of tired I'm knowing the road it's
the morning I'm not wearing a robe you
know so there's no I definitely I
definitely feel better I just like
watched our show yesterday I'm like damn
this sucks yeah no we just did not have
what it takes yesterday but now we know
why so I feel good knowing why we
apologize for the perm Mike's super
short show that's what we should have
called it show but today we have a great
show because we have tons of stories
we're doing dear toasters because it's
so not only should you not forget to
hump someone you love
you should also reach out to us if you
need advice tear toasters at gmail.com
is a completely anonymous it's a email
account you can write in to us about
anything that's troubling you from
quarantine Jew boyfriend to any of that
stuff and we will do it in our dear
toaster segment at the end of this show
when we have great ones for today which
I'm excited about I do I do love to your
toasters I'm not gonna lie I love like
it's like I'm in no position to be
giving advice yet here I am giving
advice um yeah I love here toasters too
I love hearing about what's going on in
your guys's life maybe feeling better
about like what's going on in my life or
like having a reason for all of the
lessons that I've learned in my life to
be able to like impart some wisdom so
all in all it's it's a great segment yes
it is also laundry day here at my house
so if you're watching on YouTube which I
hope that you are and don't forget to
subscribe
forgive the stack of pillows and the
empty mattress behind me I'm just so
clean so clean yeah you washed your
sheets last week - I'm on a weekly
schedule yeah oh I have two things to
say about yesterday's show the first is
that I got so many messages and I must
apologize and issue a correction when we
were talking about Kaitlyn Bristowe
going on Dancing with the Stars I was
talking about Shawn booth how we went on
Instagram and told everyone about this
new person in his life and I guess it
was a joke that like completely went
over my head because the whole time he
did this long series of Instagram
stories then unlock line I did tap
through quite a bit and this whole joke
was like he knows everyone's wanting to
know if he's dating someone and he made
a joke that there is someone new in his
life but it's a new dog because very
sadly his old dog that he used to have
with Caitlin Tucker
passed away recently so he got a new dog
so I need to issue a correction Trump
boots does not have a new girlfriend he
does have a new dog and the second thing
is someone actually just got a DM this
morning that made me really happy
because you know yesterday we reported
that cameo is now doing like zoom
sessions with your favorite celebrities
so apparently they also reported that on
that story on Howard Stern and they did
the same game as us like Howard and
Robin we're like finding the celebrities
Jessie how much they cost and it's like
we have the same jokes as Howard Stern
wow that really that's something special
something it's nice you know when peers
in the industry are complimenting one
another
yeah just like some like-minded peers
that's that's so fabulous love love to
see it um wait I feel like I had
something to say about the Sean boo
thing but mm it'll probably come back to
me
yes that was my mistake and I'm not
above you know knowing that I'm wrong so
I wanted to come on here the amount of
messages that I got was tagged in that I
G TV video so many times and I'm glad
that you're clearing the air I'm sad
that he's not in a fabulous relationship
like we expected with like a fabulous
famous person we were like really like
hypothesizing about like who it could be
and it's just I just wanna say though
just because like the new leading lady
in his life was turned out to be his dog
like doesn't mean that he's not in a
relationship I mean I know he might be
trying to divert cuz maybe he said that
and then people were like ooh and then
he was like oh this is too much it's
just my dog I mean if you were to ask me
like who the top 10 bachelors in
Nashville are like Sean Booth would be
one of them 100%
so it's he's definitely hit like has
someone or maybe two people who knows
who knows well we'll keep you posted if
we hear about any new leading ladies or
dogs that he may stumble upon yes we
will because that's what we do here at
the morning toast we invade people's
personal lives and we're gonna do that
right now with our Fast Five yeah you
want to get right into it is there
anything else you wanted to update
people on or speak on um no I just
really spent most of the day yesterday
watching Real Housewives of Potomac I'm
on season three reunions and how
glamorous are the reunions like they
aren't available they're really really
glamorous but the one that I'm watching
right now it's like a little bit too
much of everything like they just like
it's too much it's it's far too much
like some people have great looks
individually but like all together it's
far too much um so yeah this reunion was
just like a little blind I understand
the cut like well colourful on the set
and like it was it's too much so you
know ever since I found out that very
interesting factoid that Bravo designs
the reunion sets to be inspired by the
location they took their trip on I never
knew that and I watched like ten years
of housewives before knowing that
and I see the reunions through like such
a different lens ever since finding that
out if you don't know they like take
design inspiration from the location
that they take a trip to so they take
multiple trips every year but there's
always like one big trip usually
international and design their reunion
sets like have nods to you know the
French Riviera or wherever they went
right so that's where I am right now
they just got back from kin which was
like so unbelievably paddy let's say one
of the best has ice trips I've ever
watched period including like the
activities and the drama like all of it
together the looks like hurt attention
the location like I was just salivating
but so the set is supposed to be like
Frenchie vibes and I just it's it's like
cluttered vibes it they could have done
so much better with making it more of
like the Mediterranean instead it's like
more beauty and the beast' like so
fabulous no no it's it's too much but
anyways I digress um let's get into it
shall we
let's get into it into the past I swear
is that you need to know before you wake
up and take a bite out of your morning
toast and yes you didn't say anything
untrue Jackie and I'm really getting
desperate and Quarantine to find new
ways to transition into just telling the
audience and being upfront honest
transparent that today's episode you
know it's gonna be great because it's
brought to you by Felix gray glasses
Americans at home are spending more time
on screens and devices than ever before
your favorite devices are a major source
of blue light phones tablets computers
TVs Kindles and more their devices make
you prone to eyestrain bright screens in
dark rooms like watching TV working on a
computer being on your phone at night or
any excessive amount of screen time can
cause eye strain which can lead to a ton
of annoying side effects like I
personally get so many migraines if I
like spend so much time on my TV and my
phone during the day but Felix great
glasses filter out 90% of the blue light
in most damaging ranges and eliminates
99% of glare through a proprietary
industry-leading lens technology only
available with Felix gray the Felix gray
frames are hand finished from durable
super lightweight italian acetate
they're gorgeous they have so many
styles so many different I mean
where my glasses in bed but still like I
want to look fabulous please you can
order online and their glasses will ship
directly to you with a hard case and a
lens cloth I've only recently come to
understand like why lens cloth is so
important like I was cleaning my glasses
to the last few years I got my dirty
like ketchup stain shirts and then I was
like wondering why my glasses were foggy
it's because I didn't have a lens cloth
and Felix Troy gives you a free one with
every pair of glasses and the best part
you can try them for 30 days risk-free
if your screens aren't easier on your
eyes send them back for a full refund go
to Felix grey glasses comm slash toast
for the absolute best quality blue light
filtering glasses on the market that's
Fe Li X G RA Y glasses dot-com slash
toast do what we did and start taking
care of your eyes feel better work
smarter shipping and returns are totally
free at Felix gray so Felix great
glasses comm slash toast for the best
quality blue light filtering glasses on
the market you truly won't regret it
especially if you have as much screen
time as I do and it's embarrassing
definitely okay first story crazy sad
too hot to handle sprint Cheska farrago
and harry josie break-up it's over for
too hot to handle stars francesca and
harry francesca who met him fell in love
with harry on the popular netflix
reality TV series broke the news to fans
in a youtube video posted on tuesday she
said quote Harry and I are not together
anymore he decided to break up with me
because he couldn't do long-distance
anymore I obviously was heartbroken I
did everything I could
according to her the split went down
during her recent visit to LA where
Harry relocated from his native
Australia she said she also had plans to
move to LA from Vancouver to be with
Harry
she said that initially she wasn't
convinced their relationship was over
for good this time she thought they were
on a break while they were like breaking
up so she didn't share anything publicly
um but then it turned out she was very
big but the vibe I was getting was like
he thought they were broken up and was
acting like a single man and that made
it clear to her that they were broken up
therefore they're broken up yeah like
I'm shocked but also not at all you know
because if you watched the show like the
way that their relationship started like
it was never gonna be successful it was
really built on a throne of lies on
Harry's part but I'm just shocked that
like he was the one who broke up with
her because I know like on the beach
everyone was like
for Harry but like in the world he's
just like one of many like good-looking
guys and Francesca is literally too hot
to handle so I just always thought she
had the upper hand in the relationship
and I'm really shocked but he's like now
in LA like tick tock er he is so thirsty
like um I'm not shocked that he broke up
with her because he's gotten a taste of
this lifestyle and he wants more and
that doesn't include having a girlfriend
in Canada yeah well she was in loot LA
um honestly I love her Maps s with her I
was happy for her when they were in a
relationship um but I'm also excited for
like single Francesca and for B what's
up to for her to be with someone like of
her caliber like I just don't think he's
a serious guy never was might not be for
a long time so I think this is what's
best for both of them and again it's not
super surprising what was surprising was
that they were still together and like
semi engaged a year I thought I had
filmed it like that was how do you guys
like that to this I mean the whole thing
was weird were they engaged were they
not engaged they just kept talking about
like getting married part of me thinks
they really wanted to be like going
strong um when the show came out because
I think that they definitely like were
in love but they were probably motivated
by like the fame and the Instagram
followers like they're the most followed
people Francesca is 4.7 million when I
checked last night and Harry has 4
million which is crazy for a guy so I
think they wanted to really run with it
I think they both have like aspirations
and when it comes to their career and
they wanted the best possible chance
when the show aired and I truly respect
the hustle but um there was always an
element of weirdness like they were so
serious but then when you did the math
the show came out like a year after it
was filmed and after they filmed they
took an 8 month break so technically
like when we got to know that they were
together in real life and it only been
like four months but it seems like two
years yeah that's a good point yeah I am
I'm sure I'm sad for Francesca I'm sure
how he's like being a fuck-boy I'm like
100% sure Harry is like gonna join the
hype house or something because he's
like all over my tik-tok for you Paige
yeah that's he I don't see him I don't
follow him I haven't heard from him
since but like I could I see that vibe
for him
so in terms of Netflix shows and the
success rates we have none from too hot
to handle but we still have Lauren and
Cameron from was that your called lie
love is wind I'm still with Amber and
Barnet
yeah what about Giannina and the other
guy you know you know what's so
interesting about these shows it's like
they become global conversations like
everyone is talking about them they get
podcast like and then in a matter of
days it's irrelevant like it's just
crazy how big they get like Francesca
told us she came on their show and said
ariana grande and Justin Bieber like
followed her and Harry from the show and
if they just become so big and then
nothing like there's really no follow up
I feel like Lauren and Cameron from
lebas Wine have become like bonafide
influencers yeah they're like the only
ones who I feel like have long-term
potential in terms of gamers I mean
maybe if you followed then like if you
follow Jimena and Damien is her man's
name um then you would keep up with them
and then you'd realize like they're
still up to stuff um like that's how I
feel by Francesca because I follow her
you know
yep but see I think the true test of
relevancy it's like if I don't follow
you will your names still come across my
desk
yes but it's exercise of relevancy for
everyone and like a lot of people like
things that they're relevant and then
I've never heard for like I don't hear
from you so right and my favorite thing
to do is like if I follow people on
Instagram and their stories just make it
seem like they're everything of the sort
I will mute them for a while to see if
their name comes across my desk in any
other way just like know if they are
everything of this order if they're just
like promoting themselves and hiding
themselves up there just hiding
themselves up and like they're just
shining the light on themselves which is
which also works oh no also works it's
just like a genuine curiosity I wish I
could say the person that I did this
with because like it was just such a
fabulous feeling like her Instagram was
just so out of control I feel like I
might know who you're talking about or I
don't know I can think I'm not sure I
feel who I feel the same way where it's
like it seems like you're everywhere but
are you just on your page posting all
the time yeah it seems like you're
everywhere are you - yeah let's find out
yeah let's find out well sad to see a
you know a young couple breakup but I do
think that this is for the best for
each of them they both have fruitful
pads and them yeah it'll be fine they
have millions of followers farrago the
label swimsuits she's doing fun she's
doing fine
okay next story little and reality TV
news as well MTV cuts ties with Alex
combo and will minimize his role on
Siesta Key siesta key is saying adios to
Alex
combo the MTV hit announced on Tuesday
night on Twitter that it was severing
ties with him going forward and that it
would be quote editing the current
season to minimize his presence recently
resurfaced Instagram post captured the
star using a racial slur in a comment
and engaging with racist content posted
on the app the show's third season
premiered last night and his air time
was limited to a single shot of the back
of his head according to Us Weekly MTV
apparently also cut down the premiere
from its originally promoted two hours
runtime to 54 minutes so last night
theistic he premiered it was meant to be
two hours um
they cut out all scenes about with Alex
compo the baby and the girlfriend and
everything so it wound up being 54
minutes in an effort to completely take
him out of the show since um racists
content has resurfaced from his account
I'm like shook at the turnaround time
those MTV editors because all this
information literally came out early
evening last night and the Shepherd made
it like 8 o'clock 9 o'clock so I'm just
like genuinely curious how they actually
got him out but they like really took
him out like this is just reminding me
because I just watched this season of
RuPaul's Drag Race where Sheree PI there
was some crazy accusations about her
like catfishing young actors and they
totally cut out her storyline but she
was still like in the show like you saw
her multiple times for episode even
though she didn't talk so the fact that
they like they erased all memory of Alex
compo when they showed things at his
house they refer to it as his parents
house they said Gary's house like I just
honestly like it was it was vanish like
never to be seen again
yeah vanish I mean he is like the waters
better term piece of [ __ ] he's like his
behavior on the show before the show off
the show like everything it all is the
same person and like
it the way that he talks to women about
women treat like everything about him
like we don't need to see this man on
television anymore like this is not what
people need to be seeing or having as
God forbid like role models and so an
MTV I feel like has actually given him
like a lot of slack here's the shark the
shark yeah I mean we should have known
the first season premiered a video of
like him and his friends on their boat
like caught they caught on a fishing rod
like a mini baby shark and literally
drove a hundred miles an hour dragging
the shark on behind the boat like it was
the most horrible video ever and that
there was nothing so I agree he's gotten
like many um passes because his dad is a
producer of the show yes and his dad
like kind of invented they show like the
dads sold it like came up with the ideas
sold at MTV um but now he's out for good
and you know what as even like as the
storyline progresses like yes he's
having the baby actually just had the
baby in like real time um
but the kids are off doing their own
thing and like he just and the energy he
brought to the show is just always so
like dark and and it just it made me
angry
ya know I will not miss him for a
multitude of reasons I think that this
is you know good for lack of a better
word yeah goodbye like even even seeing
his face like I guess yeah he just gives
bad vibes so social media posts were
abhorrent like really some of the work
I've seen a lot in my day and it was
some of the worst I've seen some of the
most offensive some of the most just
blatantly racist like it said to chill
down my spine a hundred percent like
sick sickening okay well goodbye
Alex new season of CSI Quito is poppin
I'm just so excited like for them to get
into like where we are now with the cast
and crew because Juliette's new
relationship is just everything to me no
and her man is rich right she found like
a nice decent oh we don't know him yet
but just based on like Instagram he
seems like a nice decent Alex comp oh
yeah which is all you can really ask for
yes okay next story is a bit of an
update from a story from like six
months ago but it really had taken the
world by storm at the time when TI said
that he goes to the gynecologist with
his daughter and like checks up on that
hymen mom but now TI's daughter deja is
tearing up while addressing the comments
about her gynecologist appointments that
her dad had mean
TI's daughter is opening up about how it
felt to hear her father discuss making
yearly trips to the gynecologist in
order to check on the status of his
daughter's region me during Monday's
episode of Ti and tiny friends and
family hustled aja Harris talked about
the immediate fallout of the rapper's
remarks while she was on vacation quote
things are completely uncomfortable for
me right now she said we're all together
in this house do I have to see my dad
and be around him and we're in a foreign
country so it's not like I can leave and
get away I'm scrolling on Twitter and I
see that I've been tagged in a post the
only word that I saw was gynecologist
and I didn't even need to read the whole
title because I just knew my heart sank
very shocked hurt angry and embarrassed
I mean honestly I'm definitely
embarrassed for sure she told her
cousins I'm trying to put it in the back
of my mind so I'm not really thinking
about it I know it's not healthy but
I've been doing that since I was a child
so now we're seeing like how the
situation played out back when on their
show yeah I mean I don't even remember
because my memory so bad I don't
remember reporting on it but I'm sure um
we mentioned like how awkward she felt
and uncommon yeah it was actually a day
that you were out of town I did the show
with Margo I remember because of the
episode was titled hymens and headbands
but um because we both wore headbands
but um but I think I then I brought it
up to you again I just like want to get
your thoughts and I'm pretty sure that
was the vibe it's awful like I feel I
feel so bad for her and now it's like
I'm glad that she got to address it like
we got to see her side of it but now
it's like the conversation gets brought
up again on social media is episode just
aired even though we were done talking
about it six months ago so um like this
is it was not a funny joke when he made
it I don't even know if it was a joke
but like some things like and I get that
people are famous and they have reality
shows but like some things can be kept
private yes I agree he went on read
Table Talk and was and explained that he
was very much exaggerating about his
presence in the
gynecologists office um but that it
became really like headline news it was
people were shocked I mean because it
was shocking read Table Talk is becoming
like a go-to platform like for people
just to like explain themselves like I
can't I can't
like underestimate how many times I'd
like seen someone on read table talk and
like totally change the way that I see
them yeah
great platform I mean yeah Jordan once
obviously okay next story a bit of an
update on Kelly Clarkson and Brendan
black black stocks divorce apparently
their issues were exacerbated amid
quarantine Kelly Clarkson and Brandon
Blackstock split shocked fans and even
their loved ones but sources tell people
the couple have been facing issues for
some time quote it just came out of
nowhere their marriage was so strong as
a source so which one is it with busy
careers and for kids any cracks in the
marriage became amplified when they self
isolated in Montana amid the corona
virus pandemic over the last couple of
months it was a stressful time says the
source quarantining in montana
exacerbated any issues i mean that was
my theory they've quarantined in like a
little cabin with one bathroom and yeah
that's gonna that's gonna highlight
existing issues it's not always gonna
lead to a divorce but it's not gonna be
happy go-lucky
i just feel like this article is like a
PR spin and it's like such a convenient
um
explanation because everyone's like
quarantine we're driving each other
crazy but like when you're a millionaire
with multiple homes like just go to
another house like i really just don't
feel i do think that there's something
more here and i know what the blinds say
they say that he was cheating quite a
bit and i'm sure that that's true so
just don't like don't give me this like
tabloid facade i know but you know it's
sometimes the tabloid facade just like
is the truth i feel like that's what
happened with Jake have Jay and Kristin
Cavallari like whatever like the news
fun I can't say more there I think they
really just glossed over like maybe yeah
I agree I mean and there's never one
reason for a divorce
especially divorce where you have kids
and you've been together for a while and
there's history there so I'm not
like a detailed report but this is just
not it like I know it like I know it in
my bones
yeah okay fine fine whoo baby suck
people exclusives
I usually trust you people in soon I
usually trust the people exclusive like
yeah people has actually managed to like
get out because they're sold at the
airport around Us Weekly Star magazine
okay in Taj I call the trash with
complete lies and fabrications but they
have really managed to make themselves
like a more like a humanitarian I
probably completely agree like they do a
lot of sovereignity
they do a lot of just like human
interest stories and they've really the
creme de la creme the cream always rises
and they've always in oh yeah but I
always I go to people a lot yeah of
course but it's just funny because they
look like the actual magazine itself
looks so similar it's like all that like
the National Enquirer and like all the
fake ones and they're always sold in the
same like rack at the supermarket or the
airport Hudson news so it's just funny
because it's actually not really like
that I think it's a trustworthy source
too and if I read something in people
like it's my understanding that it's
confirmed
yeah and I feel like a lot of supper
tees have good relationships with people
and like just give people the exclusive
because I they trust that it will and
also not that I will be in an airport
for quite some time but it is a fabulous
airport read because it's got this
celebrity gossip great photos human
interest pieces you know heroes who you
know rescued a man who was you know
holding his 25 daughters in a dungeon in
Idaho and then they also have crossword
puzzles and lots of games so really
could fill a two hour flight the
crossword puzzle the people crossword
puzzle is the puzzle like it's the best
in the biz I usually buy it at the
airport just for the puzzle then I
bought a book on Amazon of like People
magazine puzzles but you know what it's
weird to bring a book of puzzles around
but see you is what I learned so greedy
no and then like I did all the good ones
and then I guess I kept like having to
see the bad ones that like we're from
you know likes maybe soap opera category
which I don't watch like they did it
categorized and they just did all the
good ones I don't know so all I'm saying
is People magazine
not to thank so funny like in a
celebrity crossword puzzle like I can
actually do it blindfolded in ten
minutes like I can do it no question I
don't think I've ever successfully done
like a a regular crossword puzzle and
gotten one one answer right yeah I think
I tried that they are much harder than
anything even like the easy ones they're
impossible yeah because like they ask
for a word 4 letter word that means this
there's a million four-letter words that
mean that and then it's like you have to
get the other answers in order to figure
out which letters work and it's like
it's two up in the air yeah I agree okay
are you ready for our fifth and final
story that was so fast yeah I know but
it's a little more award show news that
nobody asked for it yet here we are
Jimmy Kimmel is set to host an executive
produced the Emmy Awards on ABC my god
again it did he host them before oh yeah
it says Jimmy Kimmel is your name host
everything like where where is someone
else where is a woman wears a black
person like I'm done and I'd like Jimmy
Kimmel kind of and I like Jimmy Fallon
but like it's enough yeah it's enough
the Jimmy's and and James Corden and I
think James is just another name for
Jimmy right when I say Jimmy's I named
James sweet Jimmy is another name for
James really so the three of them yes I
am right like if your name's James
Fallon and James Kimmel are totally
their names I'll look it up 100% it's
like if we had to Williams and a bill
they're all Williams so they're all
really James's and they knew every
Thomas Fallon is his name told you
that's crazy
the James is crazy it's it's it's enough
like award shows are really becoming so
routine and anytime they do something
out of the box with a host it's
immediately better like even when they
have no host or when they had Ricky
Gervais Slyke when they do someone like
slightly different than the Jimmy's it's
so much better and like I'm sure he'll
do a good job and I'm not saying
anything bad about Jamie but it's like
we've got to change switch things up we
got to kick it up because you want to
know why it's like this quarantine has
changed us forever it has changed the
world what's happened in quarantine has
changed just like we are no longer
accepting the jimmies I'm sorry we're
not know what like we are changed people
and we want better and it's not gonna
cut it
yeah he said though this is funny he
said I don't know where we'll do the
show or how we will do this or even why
we are doing this but we are doing it
and I'm hosting it haha Jimmy what a
funny joke your whole team of writers
that's what you came up with I'm done I
need someone funny and you know what
what award show is us a nice give it to
Kevin Hart controversial David but like
why I mean honestly I'm sure it actually
was more like no one else wanted to do
this because first of all like no one
wants to host an award show it's a
thankless job and you're just gonna
become like have a big target on your
back to like it's a thankless job 3 um
it's like impossible to to be good at it
like everyone will like come for you in
other words and will lure and for this
is the Emmys this isn't even the Oscars
so it's like is it worthless there are
so many fabulous like comedians and
funny people who are on TV shows yeah
who wouldn't love the job I'm just
saying like I guess the Emmys is kind of
like low rate but still you could find
Hollywood is full of their sponsors and
he says low rate but it's part of the e
God so it's something was Sandra oh and
Andy what's his name Milonakis what does
me know I'm Andy Grammer no ass out Andy
Samberg yeah yeah there's like four guys
in Hollywood that looked just like him
and they're all named Andy so apologies
they were good like they were Golden
Globes that was different like we just
we've got to keep moving like we're the
jimmies like it's like Jimmy Carson like
it's like we gotta move on yeah I feel
like they could even think out of the
box like it doesn't necessarily even
have to be an entertainer like what
about a
magician what about influencers Alton no
honestly like they should have Joe Rogan
to it or Howard Stern yeah well that's
just like to more like straight white
men but you know what I mean yeah no I
really think that like they should have
a magician host it and like table it and
it would just be something different
we need like not only diversity within
the hosts but like diversity and humor
like the Jimmy's tell the same joke see
the same like identify barriers
diversity of thought yeah like it's just
it's enough like I'm so good and by the
way I can't stress enough like I
actually do like Jimmy Fallon like I do
I do I like Jimmy Kimmel and I really
love James Corden no no hate against Sam
but it's just like I'm a consumer and
I've had enough yeah well I don't think
you were gonna watch that I mean anyway
so unless I get nominated true okay well
those are the past five stories and I
feel so that you needed to know them and
now you do so and now we're able to jump
into our dear toaster segment which once
again is our advice segment if you ever
want to write in we'll always keep it
anonymous and you can email us dear
toasters at gmail.com here's our first
one dear Jackie and Claudia I've been
with my man for almost five years now
everything has been great we are engaged
and getting married at a small ceremony
soon party to follow love that he
started working a second job during
corona turned some extra money and I
think that may have something to do with
all this a few weeks ago he started
acting really strange turning away from
me while using his phone on his phone he
would he was on his phone the second he
woke up until he fell asleep this
probably went on for two weeks he was
being very distant and getting snippy
with me over little things he was just
acting like he wanted nothing to do with
me one night he was up late playing
video games and I came out to living
room and he had a hard-on shook I did
not think that that was going there whoa
I thought that's weird since when does
Call of Duty get you that excited I
mentioned it to him the next day and he
laughed it off and said he was seeing
that I was seeing things as if after
five years I don't know what an erect
penis on my man looks like that's
insulting then one night when I was
sleeping I woke up to pee and I saw he
was wasn't in bed next to me I opened
the bedroom door which is directly next
to the bathroom and he was standing
facing the toilet with his phone in his
hand
since someone at 1:00 a.m. when he
turned any saw me he quickly pulled up
his shorts and flushed and walked over
to this thinking I could tell I it
startled him his entire tone was so
weird he was staying up later than me
every night which was unusual then out
of the blue it just stopped he started
talking me more and acting less
suspicious but I never really confronted
him again I still have this weird gut
feeling that he was doing something
shady and it won't go away yesterday
while we were out chopping us on the
password for his phone I usually don't
snoop but I feel like I have to check
his phone and see if I find anything am
I crazy or do I go through his phone
tonight while he's sleeping sincerely a
stressed toaster ooh
so I mean something's going on like you
have grounds for concern like I am
officially concerned I am not really
four I mean I'm not really going through
someone's phone like disagree I'm so
about like privacy
honestly like because I just think about
well how I would feel if someone did
that to me and like it would be like
honestly if I found out that someone was
going to my phone I would break up with
them because that is just like a
complete lack of trust like I just
Claudia you and I are different on that
like we've had this discussion like if
your man that kept a journal and you
found it would you read it I wouldn't
you whoa a journal no because he's not
messaging his girlfriend in his journal
no nobody's matter cuz she's a matter of
privacy like and being like just wanting
being curious but see I think that
there's a way to snoop while still
respecting someone's privacy like I and
by the way i snooped through Ben's phone
all the time I never open messages with
his family there's nothing like crazy in
there they're just like sending each
other memes
I don't read his stuff with his friends
I just look for on Saved phone numbers
and mysterious girls who I don't know
and you know what I never find anything
and part of me thinks that Ben doesn't
cheat on me because he knows I was
talking find out you got to scare them
yeah I think that like it seems like if
you asked him about it you're not he's
not gonna be forthcoming like you do
have to do a little bit of snooping I
just I don't I guess you just gotta get
in there but what you have to be quick
and you and you can't look at things
like you can't see if he's like you can
search your name and see if he's talking
about you like no I agree
that's unfair that's his this scenario
you have been given reason to doubt and
therefore you have been given one
allowance to snoop but you have to do so
respectfully don't go like searching for
things you're looking for one thing and
one thing only like not to hear that he
called you annoying to his friends like
he's allowed to do that
you are you have to respect you can't
read to stuff with his friends you have
to look for females and unsaved phone
numbers that's it and also check like
facebook Messenger because sometimes
they get like shady or like what's out
but how do you know that maybe he has
the theme the person saved is like
Daniel you know I know your man is a
serial cheater yeah I don't think he
would keep it as a nun same phone number
cuz that's too that's too likely one off
II like this is a an ongoing problem
here's the thing boys are not that smart
and for the most part like they're like
probably not even smart enough to delete
the text messages like that's for sure
yeah I don't
but that means safe to go through every
single message honestly you just go to
his camera roll and go to the search bar
and right boobs or bra brass the air
then all photos of people and bras will
come up and then yeah what he's looking
at that's a good idea or you can go to
photos and check the trash yeah it's a
base yeah there's places you can check I
just in this situation in this situation
it's gotten to that like he knows only
[ __ ] you're saying you're saying that
this has started because he got a second
job you're also engaged like there is a
chance that he's trying to like do
something to surprise you um and like
whatever no surprise that worth
questioning your relationship on it all
by the way [ __ ] surprises is what I want
to say that's how I feel generally
speaking here's my thing about surprises
like you will now spend say he's doing
something really nice for you in six
months and like he's up all night
you will spend the next six months
wondering if your man is cheating on you
to have like one moment I'm surprise me
like Oh surprised cool as opposed to
like getting excited for the next six
months about what he's planning for you
like in any case between a surprise or
not a surprise
[ __ ] surprises I just don't think that a
surprise would mean him in the bathroom
on his phone and having a boner in the
living room like I I actually I see how
it because I
they could be separate situations maybe
he took his phone to the bathroom
because he is trying to support like he
didn't want you to see something and
then maybe he honestly had a separate
boner like just jerking off on the couch
separately like they don't have to be
correlated yeah I just um I'm not buying
it any of it go through his phone
next up hey Claudia and Jackie love love
love you guys try to get everyone I know
to listen to TMT love you I recently
broke up with my boyfriend of a little
over a year he wanted forever and I
wanted right now
we were just never truly on the same
page when I broke up with him he said
I'll bring your stuff back sometime this
week so I waited after over a week
passed and he brought the stuff back to
my parents house where I don't live and
he knows that my mom brought me the box
and in in it was every card I ever gave
him a bunch of sentimental gifts I'd
given him the very expensive anniversary
gift I got him and here's the worst part
his mother returned the Mother's Day
gifts I gave her that was a low blow so
now I'm wondering do I get petty and
return some if she gave me do I say
something about how his mom shouldn't be
fighting his battles for him I want him
to know this is part of the reason that
we broke up that he lives by his mom's
word and never his own do I live leave
it alone also he gave me a Tiffany
necklace for anniversary that I did not
intend on returning since he gave his
gift back do I give mine back sincerely
a bitter toaster absolutely not like if
you know if you don't like it just throw
it in the trash like you don't need to
get it to him because then you're being
Petty and being petty shows that you
care if he never hears from you again
and doesn't get his gifts back and keep
that Tiffany necklace sell it I don't
care what you do with it or wear it for
if you enjoy it um then you're really
like on another level of not caring like
him going and getting the Mother's Day
gifts like you know how much time he
spent doing all of that [ __ ] finding all
of the cards like he cares and he's a
loser and you're cool and you don't care
and you're not gonna spend time like
gathering all of the different gifts
from different people just to show him
that you don't care instead you're just
gonna keep wearing the Tiffany necklace
because you truly don't care who it came
from you don't care about that person
and like you broke up with him so like
let him have this like he thinks it was
like a dig let him think that he got to
you because you at the end of the day
sounds like you don't really care about
him anymore and you just want to move on
with your life so if you start being
petty it's like you're along dating this
whole thing where it's like you wanna
move on with your life by keep your
necklace keep wearing it it's pretty
it's from Tiffany's and
all that [ __ ] out it doesn't matter I
don't think that you need to engage with
him anymore let him think that he like
won because you broke up with him and he
was one who wanted to be with you for
forever and you don't want to be with
him so like let him have something I
didn't really register that she broke up
with him um that makes it like a little
sadder for him but you know what
sometimes like someone breaks up with
you because they think there's some sort
of way and then in the break-up you can
show them actually like I wasn't who you
thought I wasn't you made a mistake and
no he just [ __ ] cemented that you
made the right choice and thank you for
that clarity sir that's true like the
way in which you act in a breakup can
actually have implications on whether or
not you get back together with this
person because people show how ugly they
are in breakups and then you never want
to get back together with them again but
if somebody handles something like so
maturely and you're like damn maybe he
was wise beyond his years maybe we
should get back together mm-hmm but
definitely don't get involved just be
thankful for the clarity final one ready
you're gonna like this one hey Claude
and Jackie how you learn love you guys
so much make me laugh every day question
I've been dating a guy for eight months
now pretty sure he's the one the only
problem is I haven't farted in front of
him but he hasn't bharden in front of me
in my past relationships the guy always
rips one and that breaks the ice it
makes me feel comfortable enough to
start ripping back but this guy I swear
does not break wind it's so weird
we spend days and nights together often
and I've even gone on road trips
together and gas is non-existent for him
what should i do should I wait till he
does or should I take the initiative how
long was it before you guys farted in
front of your husbands thanks in advance
well Jackie is an amazing story but
before she says I just have to say if
you want to hear about my experience
party in front of my husband for the
first time I tell a hilarious story and
my comedy special about it which is now
available for pre-order it comes out
June 30th so less than two weeks
you can search disgraced queen on itunes
or you could tap the link on my bio on
girl with no job fabulous comedy special
everyone's gonna enjoy it and they talk
about partying in front of pen but
Jackie actually is the true expert in
this scenario yes I'm the expert in
bodily bowel functions in front of your
significant other because I was like I
thought that when I got married like I
would never take a [ __ ] even in my own
house like I would have to go down the
street maybe visit a friend and like
then take a [ __ ] because like my husband
would never
Zack and I started dating and we spent
every waking minute together and I
actually got sick from not going to the
back
when I need it to and so you know I woke
up in the middle of the night and he had
to take me the hospital and I think for
him like he'd rather know I'm taking a
[ __ ] then have to go to the hospital in
the middle of the night so that really
cleared that up when it comes to farting
though I still don't just like fart with
the bandit in front of my husband if one
slips out like I'll just for him like oh
my god the furniture is moving like
that's crazy
um but I totally understand how you feel
now I'm gonna give you a suggestion that
I think will help break the ice because
um just farting is so weird until you've
done it I think you need to go on a
double date with a couple that that is
like been together for a long time a
friend that you can talk to you and be
like to her like I need you guys to
bring up like farting in front of your
significant other and then like they'll
talk about it and you guys and and maybe
he'll be like you know what's weird dude
like I never fart or like I only SBD
like I don't think you've ever heard me
farted like you guys will start talking
about farts and just take the taboo out
of the conversation like now when I hang
out with you and pen and like even my
friends like all we talk about it's like
do be fired in front of our boyfriends
like so I think if you bring another
couple into it it'll make you guys
realize that it's not as serious as it's
becoming it's just so funny like how
different we are like literally there is
nothing I won't do in front of men and
vice versa like it's just I don't it
doesn't even register for me and I
honestly maybe I'm too comfortable
because I fart everywhere like I'll sit
on men's lap and I'll fire on him and
then I'll like throw me on the other
side of the couch but like honestly I
just it also it depends per person like
I'm a gassy person like I take a sex all
the time like I am just that girl so
some people actually like don't fart
that much which is just so strange to me
cuz like how are you human so it's
definitely different per person and per
couple but I'm all for it like but I
didn't fart for like the first year like
yeah all that [ __ ] but then once you do
it's just like such a better way to live
your life like you want to be in your
own home like feeling like a stranger no
fart no I mean for me a better way to
live my life is like knowing that you
know my husband who can probably count
on one hand the amount of times he's
heard me fart like that makes me feel
good and like proud um but that's not
for everyone also you need like I know
you think that you're an doesn't fart
but like everybody does fart so like he
has fart thoughts as well and maybe he
thinks like you're such lady he doesn't
want to do it
and now it's like my husband farts in
front of me and not just like that's
cool I want to encourage him to do that
I just don't feel like participating in
the same way so um definitely get in
some some buffers to help have you guys
have this conversation because it's
something that every single couple goes
through and every and whoever you bring
to the table to have the conversation
like we'll have a funny story about it
that'll just open the case wide up or if
you don't have couple friends like find
a podcast that talks about this and like
on your next road trip like just start
listening to it no but like then guys
look at each other in your life blushy
like yeah but like it'll open up like oh
just I I think it's good it'll open up
just like a whole other conversation
like you know things can get stale after
eight months yeah I think when you have
other people there that sort of take the
heat off of you it it will help ya um so
those are our deer toasters thank you
guys so much for writing in and don't
forget to write in for next week dear
toasters at gmail.com it's always kept
anonymous don't forget to preorder my
comedy special it's at the link in my
bio on girls no job Instagram account
you can also just search disgraced queen
on itunes $13 premium content i truly
appreciate all the support maybe review
and that's all she wrote oh well she
actually wrote that there's two
housekeeping announcements one
tomorrow's episode will be podcasts only
so no video and Friday there will be no
episode because it is June and we will
be commemorating June teen so no episode
Friday but we will be discussing just
mercy the toast movie of the week on
Monday it gives you a little more time
to watch if you're unfamiliar with
Judeans make sure which to be honest I
was not entirely sure what it was um
because everyone thinks like
emancipation proclaimation slavery
undead actually not true so research
should learn more about Juneteenth it's
a fabulous day and we're gonna be
commemorating it like a lot of people
around the world and I'm trying to make
it a national holiday take work off all
that stuff which is great and we're
gonna be doing that here so Monday will
be our recap of just mercy and our
highlight of black owned businesses and
yes tomorrow will be podcast only thank
you guys so much for listening to
morning toast selenium morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found sin Spotify iTunes stitcher Public
Radio I have read no Kaspar all places
whoever you listen to podcast - the
morning doesn't leave a five-star view
about our beautiful stunning and smart
we are we love you guys so much we hope
you have a fabulous day and we'll see
you here are you tomorrow bye